our goal was over the six months to show
why Europe needs more investment in
research and innovation the increased
coherence and openness of the European
Union research innovation partnerships
will contribute to simpler and more
accessible 9th Framework Programme
today we also discussed how to address
the global challenges through the
research and innovation
more specifically we focused on a
mission oriented approach to funding
research the key issues are that we need
to address and they're very clear in the
council conclusions are first the need
to prioritize research in innovation in
new policies provide significant funds
for the future programs the second is
the need to support in a different way
the way we look at innovation I think
that the council conclusions also talk
about is linking between science in the
citizens how do you create ways of
linking citizens to what we do but this
morning there was discussions are on the
space of our programs from Galileo
Copernicus are delivering high quality
services that had major economic
benefits on earth so space problems also
give us opportunities to react to
disasters and to security threats but
not only that space research and space
industry leads to the creation of
completely new industries that's why
Europe has to work together any vest to
fuel tomorrow's growth and job creation